hey what's up guys my name is a cello
you've probably noticed there haven't
been any videos in a while that's not me
being lazy that's just me not having
enough time see here's the thing I'm a
full-time student at university and like
any other person I need to work to keep
myself alive so when i'm not studying
i'm working which comes to around 25
hours per week that of course leaves
almost no time to make videos but
imagine if that wasn't the case imagine
if i could spend 20 hours per week
making videos instead of working that's
where Patrian comes in patreon calm is
this awesome website i've just found
where you can pledge money per video so
instead of kickstarter where you pledge
a large amount for a large project at
one time here you pledge a small amount
for a recurring thing that way whenever
I upload a video that money comes in
pretty cool concept isn't it obviously
this only applies to videos that belong
to major series that I do such as game
programming or 3d game programming or
any other major series not update videos
like this one for example you can also
cancel or change your pledge at any time
so there's no danger so the idea is to
obviously pledge a relatively small
amount I'm going to be uploading videos
several times a week so if you pledge
twenty dollars that can build up really
fast as you can imagine see what's
awesome about this is that if enough of
you pledge even one doll in fact if
everyone here just pledges one dollar I
can quit my job and do this instead this
is awesome for both you and me as a
reward the more you pledge the more you
get ten dollars per video gets your
premium membership on my website the
channel calm and that premium membership
isn't even out yet it's coming early
next month twenty dollars gets you
access to a private email address where
I'll answer all of your questions and
one hundred dollars gets you one hour
skype call with me every time I put out
a video regardless of course I'll still
continue to put out videos when I have
time and they will always be free this
kind of content is something that I feel
is lacking throughout the internet and
also I want to add that you will always
be able to watch my videos for free
that's a promise so basically if you
appreciate my content and want to see a
lot more of it pledge any amount that
you think each of my videos is worth
it'll help me out immensely but more
importantly it'll help you out I'll have
more time in my life to make awesome
videos for you thank you